[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur la somme de nos choix
et nous ne pouvons échapper au passé
Ethan
risque de vous écouter très jeune
le monde change
la vérité s'évapore la guerre est à
notre porte
ça fait longtemps cher ami
vous n'avez aucune idée de la puissance
que je représente
qui connaît votre histoire
quand on connaît la fin
écoutez-moi le monde entier sera contre
vous
son destin a été créé devant nous écrire
le vôtre si leur arrive quoi que ce soit
vous pourrez bien vous cacher n'importe
où je vous tuerai et ça c'est écrit
[Applaudissements]
Ethan quel est ton objectif
quel est ton objectif
ultime
[Musique]
vos vies contre toujours plus à mes yeux
que
la mienne
aucune de nos vies ne doit compter plus
que cette mission je ne suis pas
d'accord
[Musique]